another week another day of West Rose as
it has been the past few weeks as it
will be the next few weeks and thank you
for clicking on my face I appreciate
that I'm glad you want to hear me talk
about the time warp we all fell into in
which we came out 10 seasons into the
future gonna give you all the special
kind of spoiler warning for this episode
we're going to talk about spoilers also
not going to be a play-by-play I say
that because I could go through the
logistics of everything that happened in
this episode and it would feel like a
lot or I could talk about the more
concise point which is the time Jump and
whether or not that was jarring what it
means how I processed it but gonna talk
about some of the events because some of
the events are very important so this
episode was the time Jump we knew was
happening figured there was going to be
a splice where they were like she's she
she now looks too young we can't we need
someone else but they committed man they
were like 10-year time Jump it's been a
decade I felt like I was reintroduced to
the world for the first time it was like
watching Game of Thrones for the first
time our house is a dragon for the first
time like in the pilot episode of Game
of Thrones into the first season it's
throwing a lot of information at you a
lot of names a lot of houses a lot of
alliances and allegiances and you're
like this is kind of melt in my brain
but it needs to do that to set up the
world which kind of makes it fun going
back when you know who the names are at
that point you're like okay I'm just
taking it in like a boss had not felt
that in Westeros again until the first
episode of House of the Dragon I was
like okay new people 200 years in the
past new allegiances let's go and
usually in a show a few episodes in it
starts to mellow out you know the names
you know the faces you know the
allegiances this show was like no up and
just flips it like a Monopoly board I
was like they're who are all these kids
the relationships have changed the queen
queen Allison's is very
she's far more self-serving at least
outwardly self-serving than she seemed
before renera [ __ ] hates her guts
there's dude the first scene renera
gives birth and she's like
all right I'll go see the [ __ ] Queen
I was like
I mean who hasn't been like all right
I'm gonna call in for work I just kind
of I have a bit of a headache it's not a
migraines you know I just I'm not
feeling it she's like I will blast out a
kid hold the kid and be like all right
I'm here
well
what but renera feeling this different
like Romero was the nucleus of the show
you know she was that which the entire
show was revolving around I thought she
did an amazing job it's like oh the
actor feels different which I mean that
happens with like a Dumbledore none of
the Dumbledore's feel like the other
dumbledores so that happens when they
change actors but I just feel like the
times are different that 10-year jump
it's like people just hate people more
not a good or a bad thing it's just a
thing that'll have to iron out in time
because I've come to know renera as a
character as she was for the first few
episodes you can feel the tension
between renera and Lennar as well it's
they don't like each other when I last
left them they had a good handshake deal
now they're just pretty much like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you sir former just one of the
ones who just I guess he doesn't age
everyone else in the episode aged
severely whether it be through a recast
or my boy Patty over here turning into
Patty Melton one episode The Dude Looks
Like Picard in the Inner Light that's
not besmirching the Inner Light it's an
incredible episode of Star Trek the Next
Generation the surf former boy toy first
of his name and Damon Targaryen are like
look I am Immortal I have inside me
blood of Kings I have no rival no man
can be my equal take me to the future of
you all if you say future tenure time
Jump the only reason I don't think
decapitating sir form or boy toy first
of his name would kill him thus you
would get his quickening is because he
actually did already fight on Holy
Ground but I had to rewind the scene
where all the kids were in the dragon
pit and they're like oh we have a dragon
for you it was a pig I was like wait who
are these kids what are their names I
just had to watch it twice what can I
say later on the episode would more
forwardly tell you who they were I
didn't know that I just thought I missed
something I did appreciate the scene
with the dragon because I feel like the
dragons they were talked up pretty big
right before the show came out they were
like we're gonna have all the dragons
feel distinctly different and now I'm
like I mean they're dragons I feel like
I know more about the relationship
between the navi and the ikron than I
know about the dragons and the people
who reside within what is known as The
House of the Dragon I just find that
strange so I like seeing a bit more
about dragons and finding out a bit more
about them but the meat of this episode
is the fact that renera's children
strangely don't look like the father so
the Queen's telling her son aegon like
you're going to be king one day and if
anyone did find out the truth about
renera's kids they'd all die it would be
Madness Bloodshed War chaos kind of
funny when I look back at me naively
talking about the pilot episode being
like yeah it looks like this fight's
gonna be between renera and her Uncle
Damon obviously and there's much more in
play than that now but there was so much
that happened in this episode it almost
felt like the show was like oh we gotta
make up for lost time we lost 10 years I
mean the Damon and Lena thing I wanted
to know more about it it's like the most
relationship he talks he's ever had with
someone I mean he's still Damon
Targaryen to his core but it felt like
there was more there to show and more
there to talk about than I got in this
episode I mean there are pregnancy
complications it's pretty much what
happened with the queen in the first
episode Damon was told like hey you can
you can cut the baby out we know for a
fact that does work for a day as you
said Damon joke's not so funny now is it
indeed the gods have a Dark Twisted
sense of humor but he seemed conflicted
I don't know how conflicted and she goes
out to her Dragon yells drakara as
Dragon hesitated you could tell this
Dragon was like I don't want to kill her
but it does it kills her and then the
next scene you see Damon Targaryen with
their kids or two daughters and they're
crying and he just walks away and I was
like how did he break the news to them I
mean was he an [ __ ] about it or was
he sad about it like how did it go down
I just didn't feel the connection or
sorrow with the situation I felt like I
should have had when her character died
but I do like in this episode you start
doubting the sincerity of the hand of a
king and him being hand of the king
because his son is Sir boy toy second of
his name who's the father of nearest
kids he definitely does seem compromised
he went to the king and he was like I
got to give up my commission so he does
take the job seriously I still
appreciate him for that but then the
littlest finger little toe whatever you
want to call him his little finger but
not quite little finger he kills the
hand and Sir boy toy second of his name
who are also known as his father and
brother so you see what I mean a lot
happened in this episode I was like I
have no time to process it before it
moves on to the next thing there could
have been a whole episode in between
people being hired and having their
tongues cut out then going to kill the
folks this episode episode 6 I felt was
the uphill battle it's a time Jump so
severe you feel like you're dealing with
different characters and different
Dynamics among the other characters when
you felt you thought you knew what the
dynamic was before the time Jump to your
credit or my credit or both we did but
now the dynamic's different I guess it's
the best way I could say it this felt
like a season premiere but I am looking
forward to next week and I've seen the
comment section people are like
obviously he doesn't watch the next week
I don't I usually don't do that I don't
like knowing what's coming next week but
in this particular case I was like I
want to know what's coming next week
There's a character coming back I'm glad
to see the character coming back but
still digging the show clocking in every
week because it is the best show that I
have to look forward to week to week all
right so House of the Dragon episode six
have you seen it did you feel the time
Jump was too jarring were you just right
there where you're like nope I got it
let's press on whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]